MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this section, we're
going to build on--
we just learned about
the relativistic Doppler
effect and redshift.
So we take on traveling
through the galaxy
from here, from Earth, towards
the center of the galaxy.
The situation is as follows.
We have Bob, who's
stationary on our planet,
Earth, and Alice, who makes
use of a new spacecraft.
This spacecraft
is able to travel
with a velocity of 0.99999998
times the speed of light.
So that's really fast.
It corresponds to a
gamma factor of 15,000.
Now, the center of the galaxy is
about 30,000 light years away.
And in Bob's reference
frame, this journey
will take about 30,000
years, because velocity
is about the speed of light.
For Alice, however, the journey
will only take two years.
So it's quite doable.
The question, now, is
what does Alice see?
Literally, what is
she going to see
while she is looking out of
the windows of the spacecraft?
Is the picture
similar to the one
we see in some of the
movies, where on the horizon,
there's lots of stars, and once
the spacecraft accelerates,
you see those dots
kind of blurry, coming
towards us, right?
Or is the situation
somehow different?
The starlight has a wavelength
of about 600 nanometers,
and the cosmic microwave
background a wavelength
of 1.06 millimeters.
So how is Alice going
to observe those two
light sources in her travel?
So I invite you
to work this out,
but also think about
the next question.
How long does it take for
Alice to accelerate from 0
to her velocity with
an acceleration of 10
meters per second
squared, which is
1g, which is very, very doable?
OK.
So I invite you to
stop the video here
and work out those
numbers to get a feel
and speculate a little bit about
how this journey is actually
going to look like.
So here's the solution.
So the light's
moving towards us,
so it's going to be blueshifted.
The velocity is given here.
And with beta, we have seen
that redshift or 1 plus
redshift is equal to the
emitted wavelength divided
by the observed wavelength.
And you find that
that factor is 10,000.
So we just have to divide our
emitted wavelength by 10,000
and find that the
observed starlight has
a wavelength of 0.06
nanometers, which is X-ray.
So she's going to be
flooded by X-rays of light
coming from the stars.
And similarly, the observed
cosmic microwave background
is going to be about
106 nanometers, which
is ultraviolet light.
The ultraviolet light--
there's a spectrum to this.
So what she's going to see is
X-rays, which she can actually
not see with her eyes.
But she will be able to see
the ultraviolet, or some part
of the spectrum, as kind
of a blurry, fuzzy kind
of background all
over the place.
So the situation is actually
different from what we just
saw in this picture.
A few more fun facts about the
cosmic microwave background.
It's actually at a temperature.
So the spectrum of cosmic
microwave background, those
photons, they correspond
to a spectrum emitted
by [INAUDIBLE] which corresponds
to a specific temperature
of 2.7 kelvin.
That is the temperature
of our universe.
This temperature was about
3,000 kelvin about 380,000 years
after the Big Bang, the age
of the universe at the time.
And so then at that time, this
corresponds to visible light.
But at that moment, the light
stopped interacting-- well,
stopped--
The likelihood for the light
to interact with something
out there in the
universe became so low
that it just
stopped interacting.
And then the frequency
changed, because the universe
was expanding.
So what we are
seeing today is kind
of a relic of the universe
at that time, at 380,000
years after the Big Bang.
And if you study the
cosmic microwave background
with some more
precision, you see
that there are
actually fluctuations
which can be analyzed.
It turns out that you can
correlate those fluctuations--
the fluctuations of the
energy density 380,000 years
after the Big Bang--
to this, the present of
today's stars and galaxies
and galaxy clusters.
So those energy
fluctuations, they
served as seeds for the
formation of galaxies
and galaxy clusters.
Quite interesting.
Today, we have about
400 of those photons--
microwave photons-- per
square cubic centimeter.
So there's quite a busy
environment around here.
So like, this little cube has
about 400 of those photons.
Now, this is a spectrum as well.
It's not just a
monochromatic background,
but it's a spectrum
which corresponds
to these temperature
[INAUDIBLE] All right.